hello and welcome to best
LittleBigPlanet levels of the week this
is episode two of a four-part series
we're making in partnership with Sony
showing off the brilliant creations of
your mind and I'm pleased to welcome
Lucy to the imagine the emotion of
torreón create dasyam here in the
GameSpot office it's a little big studio
we'll call it anyway we have three more
levels that you've picked yeah well at
least help pick and these ones pretty
sure all made a little bit credit three
unlike last week yeah it turns out that
that motorbike level great level second
level very danger was also very
dangerous all the way back in
LittleBigPlanet one but it turned up in
our search because it had been updated
in I mean technically there which is the
best kind of it didn't break the rules
let's crack on Lucy with the first of
all of us I'm not there I'm on my own
what am I supposed to stick to you now
nice face he'll love you now
Jurassic Park trailer just came out I
timely yes very timing look at that dice
head and Jurassic lovely alright let's
crack in the first thing you do move it
so service plane is on his own because
sadly this level doesn't work with two
players my heart breaks it is amazing
it's so well done it is the the intro to
uncharted 3 that someone's made I'm so
ready for this let's do this alright the
uncharted one is brilliant look as we
even start the car okay I know Aero
Natasha torsion Aeronautics etosha
narrow no torsion estate plans rudder
looked like maybe it wasn't gonna be all
that functional it looks like it's made
out of paper
oh it's Agni the Drake does technically
require having the Nathan Drake
you know the Uncharted DLC so that your
character looks right we don't have it
this is why my sac boy looks kind of it
looks great there kind of cart clive
barker's generic oh but
is gonna get a bit naked here we go
I want to attack I want to dodge l1 so
much for Taylor Ellen dodge oh I didn't
know it terrible at dodging Oh
your mistake was to only swing for the
head I know the guys stuck in the EM let
me shoot I hope he's okay okay he oh she
turns out to be made of fabric so he'll
probably bounce pop falling so it says
don't let go but I'm pretty sure in
order to jump from here to here I'm
gonna have to let go that's a
technicality
all right I'm jumping oh okay oh wait
you got a gun now a little big planet
being quite so violent
well I guess it's not really fun as I
get 15 shop enough details take that mic
here
why just get some rampage around Rambo
starters to kill everyone like Uncharted
oh no my dad I'm alive I cannot be
killed
oh I've grown hair again that careful oh
if you could grow hair that quickly we
should really better ties that oh well
the sand
oh we've landed safely I think no I kind
of like I mean crushed the cargo plane
in fact it even says LBP three crafted
the cargo plane thank you
okay so historically before we begin
this it's the decoration ceremony
everybody knows about the decoration
ceremony you're gonna have to look like
a bud cutlery drawer well you are the
letter S
that's funny cam did the exact same
thing wait what's that
I like oh look now you can see where
you're going at all times the next level
finally a little bit of two-player
alright so ridiculous this level is
called swipe battle and what its gonna
require from us I believe is some Smash
Brothers esque
gameplay okay so this is our level it's
it's fraught with danger and you know
remember how to slap oh that's right
when you jump yourself it helps that
okay don't jump on that thing cuz it
just kills you okay
my vision is based on movement if you
hold still I can see you see I don't
wait so l1 Noel l2 and r2 because I
because I hate you also we currently
store nil-nil what's that about stop
hitting me
that's it oh my god but give me that
give me that look Oh Oh your first slap
yes
chase my slap I was slapped you on your
bed oh that typically gowns okay I got
your friend level yeah that was finally
Mufasa 9 seconds left to score a point I
don't understand how we're so bad at
this
how do we both get 0 slap battle by akan
Oz 91 is good although it looks like it
could use a little work on the scoring
front I found the the best trick was to
grab and pull people to their deaths
rather than slow oh no you were doing I
wasn't what I wasn't undoing
I'll have to go you'll have a go all
right never can sweep best here we go
two one go bring it bring it bring it
I want to swim oh that was a good swim
good first sweep no no that's right all
right I mean go left
Oh potential ally lead well all the bits
where I died a little bird flap flap
flap I mean it okay roast sweet for
dinner
delicious they actually have great
flavor
stringy if you will no oh that felt good
to say blood is that that's grim little
brothers and sisters that perished on
those spikes then like the pigeon spikes
that you see on top of buildings why do
they make these all birds feel feel pain
okay jump it was too much too many swoop
one little tiny thing I was like the
worst flappy bird level checkerboard
5258 to jelly sweetheart
horrible star that's what you call a
said flora but this blood there - is
that mine I don't think that was there
before
Tower of sweep not suitable for minors
skills whoa okay okay oh okay I'm a
little envious of these skills are
pretty good okay didn't get thing at the
point I need him
I need us one of the safety you have the
points of speed
you like with the grace of a Pilate
Pilate impaled Pilate Mike's famously
yeah the enemy of the sack bird it's
meant to be baby bird or is that is that
a fully-grown swoop
I watched David Adom breath and they
didn't cover this take parrot settle
parrot so paradigm of a silly little
yellow beak the puffins there you go um
I can do that
all right so all right press the tree
yeah all right Tower of sweet bye breezy
the pro professionally breezy
I enjoyed that that was good uh mainly
because I want yeah well I mean this
this has been a week so far of very
single singular player levels with the
exception of course of slacks this laps
were there the slaps are genuine well I
think I gave more slaps and I dragged
you into the lava more as well I'm gonna
give you that as a moral victory a moral
victory but not but not an actual
tangible one in terms of the actual
measurable points you did technically
win which means that's two weeks for me
back to back the losses we did get a
couple of questions as well from last
week's episode thank you first sending
those if you would like to send more
questions you can leave them in the
comments under the video you can at
least James games and me ready said we
go we also have a hashtag
it's whatever kids are cool yeah they're
there they're coming in big these
hashtag you watch out you know what a
hashtag is it is GS LBP three I'm glad
you said that because I forgot about the
GS thank you yeah alright so first
question was from Jonathan Williams who
says did you know odd sock is female no
no but you look that up didn't you I did
to verify and yeah apparently old sock
extreme old sock is the key a little dog
like thing with a giant head be smart
720 also asks could you guys make Kevin
Van sack
yes so yes we get that's in reference to
the the character we have in Skyrim mods
which is called Kevin man Nord Kevin man
sack I thought was good that I came up
with an alternative okay Kevin van Nord
meets Bob in van chord oh that's better
okay I like does that work yeah but okay
I hope that works beast mode
it's load 720 had a great name anyway it
is time for this or that thing okay
I spent some time working on this
because I kind of you did use all of the
best ones like good afternoon
okay you know how these work right yep
quickfire yeah okay you can't screw it
up you have to say the first one that
comes into your head okay I mean you can
screw it up alright okay I'll so quick
here we go starting off with something
easy Frodo or Sam Sam map editor or the
editors map editor pop it or Bop It
I'll bop it extreme blink ball or
blink-182 don't want it too stickers or
knickers take Megatron on negativity Ron
LittleBigPlanet or little pig damn it PJ
or Duncan Oh Duncan cut them put on Anna
put Nana Foods
bene rails for fairy tales fairy tale
comes on racks Andre oh boo Alexandra I
think you're the brain
Oh pinky Marlin random or Mushroom
Kingdom
Russian Kings chip or Dale Dale Pluto
puppy or planet twine or whine why
string or yarn yards red pandas or Ned
Flanders Ned Flanders here we go
you did well you were a little slow I'm
gonna say I think you pronounce it he
pronounced it swarm swarm kisses yeah
cuz it easy the meerkat is the makeup
from the British insurance that we're
gonna have three more levels next week
hopefully picked with some more
competitive nature's but if you've built
a level in LittleBigPlanet 3
specifically
and you'd like us to try them please
send them to us
then tomorrow what kind of level would
you like to see I would like to see more
intuitive level yes yes more than if you
can also somehow make it to player I
know that wasn't technically it there
was a play on on type three there was
there was if someone wants to make that
I'd be super grateful and also someone
wants to add a legitimate scoring system
to a slap battle too I'd also like to
see what happens when four people play
that good for player level so join us
again next week for more of the best
user generated levels in the people yeah
there's gonna be me kam Li si what what
some mix of us we've already made the
intro graphics and frankly I'm not
making them again yeah so some
combination of us three if you'd like to
send in questions please do so on the
art which animals alone comments we'll
check them out if you'd like to do
another this all that written for me so
I don't have to come up with them again
again really appreciate it and but do
please send us all of your use made
levels cuz there and we'll see you back
here